( intro music )
I got started just
taking pictures
just taking pictures
I wanted to take.
And I just took pictures
I thought were weird
or different or
interesting or funny.
A cowboy roping a cat.
( audience laughter )
Could be a lady walking her dog.
Bad dogs make excellent
pictures, it turns out.
Some dogs are a little
worse than others.
But it was these
types of pictures
that got me noticed
by Geographic.
And that was 25 years ago now,
hard to believe.
As I've gone forward through
my career
I started to do more and more
stories on conservation, and
to me, good pictures should come
from the conservation side.
They could be funny or
humorous, entertaining.
They better be entertaining.
So, for a story on grizzly bears
I was given eight weeks
of assignment time
This is day two.
Notice those are
my boots up the tree.
The tops of those boots are wet,
don't ask why, exactly.
( audience laughter )
Of course, reality is
these are bears at
basically a Hollywood facility.
They train bears to fake roar
and fake maul for the movies.
And that bear is actually
not making sound
he's just opening wide
to get donut holes
tossed into his mouth
from a trainer off to the side,
so that's all there is to it.
So, I loaded up as
much as I could
for that week,
anything I could think up.
And when I did go
to Alaska finally.
I went to the most visually
loaded place that I could find
where I knew the bears were.
So, what's the story here?
Well, bears actually
tolerate us just fine.
We can't stand bears.
Bears love our garbage,
full of food and good smells,
but...
they get a little aggressive,
get into our dumpsters
they get into our bird-feeders
next and our dog food.
They break into our cabins and--
A fed bear is a dead bear.
They end up getting
shot and sold
at the state of Alaska surplus
sale, twice a year in Alaska.
So, with bears it's fairly
straight forward, you know
keep them out of the garbage,
everything is gonna be okay.
They're, you know,
they don't--
they kill one person a year on
the North American continent
so they tend to get
a very bad rap
even though we lose many times
that to domestic dog fatalities
every year in this country.
What about the more
quiet species?
What about wolves?
They're more of an enigma and
this is the problem with wolves
because people want to
view them either as
something cute, like a pet
or a blood thirsty killer.
What are wolves?
We want to know, don't we?
We're cued every
minute of every day
how to think about everything,
from our news to
who's good and who's bad
in any reality show.
But with most wildlife,
including predators
there ain't no such thing.
Wolves are just wolves.
That's it.
Story on koalas.
Shoot the weird,
the different, the idiotic.
Photograph the cute and cuddly
in the hopes that people
will see this and say
"Why does that human
mother have a baby koala?"
Well, because this is the
truth for northern koalas.
I was shocked when I
went over there. Really.
I mean, they're confined to
golf courses in the suburbs
and when they come off the
golf course, they're trapped.
They get hit by cars and they
get attacked by domestic dogs
and it's something awful.
And still the
government of Australia
would not grant the koala
in the northern part of
the country protection.
The nurses at one koala
hospital, I went to
who would've all gotten fired
had they known we were--
that their management know we
were gonna make this picture.
They saved back one week's
worth of koalas in a freezer
all killed by dogs, including
that mother and baby.
We ran that picture
around the world
and the government of
Australia changed the law
and offered protection
to those koalas
a few months after
the story came out.
Can I say that picture did it?
Sure didn't hurt,
sure didn't hurt.
So that's why we do this.
( applause )